in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrew
and Brittany are here in the house
what's up guys hey Dave how are you
where y'all from Orlando Florida very
cool welcome to Nashville and here to do
a debt-free scream oh yeah I love it how
much have you paid off twenty six
thousand seven hundred seventy one
dollars and 97 cents I love it and how
long did that take you twenty eight
months good making what range of income
we started at fifty one thousand and now
we're up to 78 thousand good job what do
y'all do for a living
we're both teachers she teaches biology
I'm a music teacher band director same
school very fun good for you so what
kind of debt was the twenty seven
thousand a little bit of everything we
had a bill me later when he bought a
tablet online dentist bill that just
needed to be paid off a credit card we
kept rolling over so we didn't have
interest and bunch of student loans oh
wow you mean everything in the world
yeah you were normal so uh a thousand
bucks a month basically gets knocked off
over two and a half years a little under
two and a half years two years and four
months to be precise and what happened
that caused you to dive into this twenty
eight months ago well I got a little
upset when we had to do a payday advance
to pay off a payday advance and so I
ended up checking out your book from the
library there was a long hold list for
your book I had to wait for 20 people to
get it before I could get it and I read
it in just about two days and then told
him he needed to read it and bought some
books here through your customer service
and that was over Black Friday of 2013
and it came with the dumping debt DVD
uh-huh and when I was watching that he
was listening and started laughing and
said well if you get the rest of these
I'll watch them with you when we bought
the home study for FPU oh wow okay
very cool good and and that got you
going mm-hmm yeah I was kind of the
holdout between us two I'm just I was
more complacent out of the two of
we were I think the first one was the
dumping that lesson she said and I was
watching it and it was entertaining I'm
like okay I can get into this we'll see
how the rest are and we'll see if I'm
still on board and I remember at one
point and the lessons you're Tom out the
free spirit you're glad that these are
funny and I was so get me on board not
let me read the rest of the books the
music guy that's not a shock yeah we
know who the free spirit is okay that
right brain side yeah that's good very
cool
good very cool we suck you in then
that's exactly what we wanted to do so
that for your benefit and then you
become the hero because you guys dive in
this together at that point and and it
starts working for the first time maybe
ever I guess have you ever been bet for
you since you've been married nope nope
for the first time since we've known
each other since we started college we
have a positive net income and that's
just never happened before one of us has
always had a student loan or something
ya know will you ever go back no never
we're done yeah we're done just like
that drop the mic we're out of here love
it
very cool well congratulations you two
very very well done what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is Andrew because you were the holdout I
tell them not to start I'm also the
senior sponsor in my school so whenever
we go through everything and you know we
have all those lessons about applying to
college and I work with our college
coordinator and our guidance counselor
and I'm the one who makes sure to tell
them you know when he's going to all
those options and he brings up say loans
and then I step and go no you know no
just you know think it out payroll apply
for all the scholarships do everything
you can
just don't do loans because take it from
me you don't want loans I hear you very
cool well congratulations you two and
Durham Brittany Orlando Florida $27,000
paid off in twenty eight months making
fifty one two seventy eight thousand
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
we're debt-free
love it
well done you two excellent job well
done
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the dayroom 2
channel I'll tell them myself that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you